e
Canadiens souffrant de la
maladie d'Alzheimer devrait
connaître une croissance
fulgurante au cours des
prochaines années.
Normand Grondin.- En 2050, le ne
Canadiens atteints de troubles
neurocognitifs sévères
aura augmenté de 150 %,
selon une étude de la Société
d'Alzheimer du Canada.
NOUHA BEN GAIED, dir. R&D, Féd.
québ. des Sociétés Alzheimer
- C'est une augmentation
fulgurante. C'est la première
fois qu'on a, en fait, des
chiffres aussi impressionnants..
- Il y a aujourd'hui
600 000 Canadiens atteints
d'un trouble neurocognitif.
Si rien ne change, ils seront
un million en 2030, puis
un million et demi en 2050.
- C'est également la même
tendance qu'on a au niveau
des personnes proches aidantes :
plus de 146 % d'augmentation
sur une période de 30 ans.
- 350 000 Canadiens consacrent
en moyenne 26 heures par semaine
à aider leurs proches.
En 2050, ils seront trois fois
plus nombreux à le faire.
Pour l'instant, il n'existe
aucun traitement efficace
pour soigner cette maladie.
- Il y a énormément de choses
qui se passent actuellement en
recherche. Et donc, on s'attend
à ce qu'il y ait quand même
quelque chose dans les cinq
prochaines années.
- Heureusement, selon l'étude,
en agissant sur les principaux
facteurs de risques connus de
la maladie - isolement social,
cardiovasculaires,
hypertension ou diabète,
par exemple - on peut aider
ceux quiceux quiceux quiceux qu.
- Ce qu'on a remarqué,
c'est que quand on gère biences,
c'est qu'on va retarder
l'arrivée de la maladie.
- Concrètement, ce délai
peut faire toute la différence.
Dr JUDES POIRIER, rech. sur la
génétique de maladie d'Alzheimer
- Si on reporte la maladie
de cinq ans, c'est presque 50 %
des cas d'Alzheimer qui
n'apparaîtraient pas sur le
radar de notre système de santé
pour la simple et bonne raison
que c'est une maladie
du vieillissement. Donc,
on va mourir de d'autre chose,
mais au moins, on ne mourrait
pas de maladie d'Alzheimer.
- L'étude indique également
que l'épidémie de troubles
neurocognitifs va frapper
certaines provinces plus
que d'autres, en raison
de leur démographie différen
L'Alberta, la Colombie-
Britannique et l'Ontario,
notamment, vont connaître
une hausse de cas plus élevée
que le Québec ou les provinces
maritimes. La Société
d'Alzheimer du Canada estime
à plus de sept milliards
de dollars la facture annuelle
imputable au traitement
des troubles neurocognitifs.
Ici Normand Grond